denis alas una contadora con 15 años de
experiencia profesional en venezuela
vive en perú desde hace más de 3 años y
se gana la vida vendiendo desayunos en
la calle el proyecto de ley que promueve
la decoración de extranjeros le hace
temer que pueda ser expulsada y me
siento vulnerable e incluso me limito
solamente a salir a trabajar
[Música]
a veces me dice mamá yo a veces quisiera
salir tengo miedo
porque yo no sé en qué momento
desafortunadamente hay un evento que me
pueda perjudicar cuando yo sé que no soy
una mala persona aunque la finalidad de
la norma es deportar a los ciudadanos
extranjeros que hayan cometido delitos
de lbi núñez considera que la iniciativa
recaerá sobre los venezolanos por ser el
grupo contra el que existe más xenofobia
y xenofobia porque todo el delito que
pasa acá en el país
la mayoría todos dicen que somos los
venezolanos los culpables porque
cualquier robo es te arrancan un
teléfono o cualquier cosa que pase en
las noticias aseguró son venezolanos la
iniciativa gubernamental que ya está en
el congreso para su aprobación
amplía la expulsión de extranjeros que
se encuentren ilegalmente en perú o se
hayan comportado al margen de la ley y
como sanción no podrán reingresar al
país por un plazo de 25 años la
propuesta es calificado por diversos
sectores como violatoria de los derechos
de la población migrante no se va a
solucionar el problema de seguridad en
perú expulsando venezolanos sin embargo
la población penal que está en el orden
para la red es cifras redondas de 90 mil
personas 80 tantos 90 mil personas
apenas según 2.8 de esa población penal
en esa zona
eso significa y si además le sumamos a
otras nacionalidades significa que
aproximadamente el 97% de la población
penal
es peruana así como de inicial así del
beat núñez más de 1.320.000 ciudadanos
venezolanos viven en perú según cifras
oficiales la vida los ha hecho
extranjeros en un país ajeno pero le
recuerdan a las autoridades que también
tienen derechos y merecen protección y
seguridad